hey guys I'm Ryan right hi I'm Lauren
gah
we're gonna watch a special trailer that
everyone is [ __ ] psyched about today
even if you don't really give a [ __ ]
about it you know you're gonna check out
the trailer for fifty fifty fifty Shades
of Grey
I was trying to reference 50 I see
shades of that with me right so 50
shades of grey everybody is the meaning
for this movie it's coming out next
Valentine's Day okay 15 obviously the
book was a very huge phenomenon yes that
pretty much everyone I know is ranked
second most read book to the Bible
actually is it really yeah fun times
wait are you serious it's really sad no
it's the second most rip know how to get
it all the straight face for some reason
let me actually honest with you I
haven't finished reading it I started
reading it I never finished it I heard
it's very sexual
it is very sexual what I think is funny
is like why this novel became such so
popular because there are a million
romance novels out there that are sexual
you know they like discuss sex acts but
why this one why is this one so
spectacular I don't know I mean I don't
know anything about it really I mean I
you guys here are things about it those
zero things about this movie oh well
then let's watch the trailer first and
then I'll explain it because that'll be
interesting okay yeah I don't know to
shits about this because you're gonna be
like kind of confused I think I don't
know why I've just never bothered to
care about anything in here
[Music]
so this is just an interview for the
newspaper I just have a couple of
questions mr. grey will see you now I'm
slightly he was quite intense smart
really intimidating do you have any
interests outside of work what about you
I'd like to know more about you there's
really not much to know about me look at
me
I am to what do you owe your success I
exercise control in all things miss
Steele I must be really more
I've started yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right I'm [ __ ] all morning let's
do this okay first of all the crazy and
loved version by Beyonce and that song
at all time was [ __ ] awesome yeah dude
I was getting yeah erotic damn that song
do you have any questions about movies
okay so swag guys falling in love and
then getting crazier with her sexual
life so it's about Christian Grey who is
into um not like BDSM looks like yes yes
but he he likes being what does he call
it the dominant anyway so he is into
being the dominant and like having girls
be a submissive that entails like not
only sex sexually but he ends up having
this contract with Johnson the the
character the girl about like he wants
to regulate like what she eats like get
her personal trainer she has to wear
what he wants her to wear oh that's when
drama comes in yeah but the thing is
like I free what the line he says but
he's like not into romance he's
basically into [ __ ] and the fact that
she's in love with him and they don't
want the same thing honestly it's like a
sexy [ __ ] right sexy stuff man see I
didn't know it because originally the
guy that was cast as Christian Grey was
that blond guy that was Sons of Anarchy
well the guy who was in Pacific Rim yeah
that guy yeah forgot his name but I
don't I don't remember what is Charlie
Charlie something huh huntin humming
something weird something like that but
I was really something about that
because I loved him I think he's so hot
but this guy I proved yeah like I was I
was watching him I'm like it's all those
body language and stare I know that he
has that like he has that like the old
man your captivating you're stealing my
soul I don't even know who that actor is
doesn't matter it doesn't matter it's
better than he's unknown makes it more
mysterious and all if I could lose that
like he's so mesmerized by her at the
whole time
he looks genuinely mesmerized it's not
like that we're calling having like a
weird like twilight like what is it I
think that's why all these girls love
these books and movies is because it's
about an average plain girl who somehow
gets the attention of the most desirable
man yeah ever and like he's just like
mesmerized by her plainness well I see I
see a little more in this girl though
this girl seems like she's like damaged
and stuff and I think guys tend to
gravitate towards girls who can be a
little bit damaged for some reason it's
not like super damage she's not she
carries herself like she is I mean do
you learn about her past uh I mean what
when I learned so far she like her
parents are divorced but there you go
she can be a really depressed kid that's
a lot of trauma that's their mature so
their stepdad she's close to their mom
sort of they are it is for parents to
understand my parents are divorced are
they yeah are you really yeah I'm so
damaged this is going down weird weird
humor territory right that was awesome
I'm sure everyone's really excited about
it yeah I'm gonna see it I you know when
I was like I was already like this is
pretty sexy and then when I got to do
like the dominatrix kind of stuff I was
like yeah this is really hot the Red
Room of pain that's what she called nice
don't wanna read this book I think it's
a book series interesting it does it I
don't think it's rated yet the movie
should be ours no well I'm very curious
on how they're going to capture all of
the color of the book in an r-rated
movie do you mean like it would have to
be nc-17
like they describe like penis
penetrating the vagina well now they
describe sex and it's not just sex it's
like they do a lot of interesting things
and how are they going to I mean guys
don't have to like show it but it would
be lame if they were just talking about
it oh yeah this is pg-13 I definitely
lose all interest no I'm sure like it's
borderline ins it may have to do it R
because no one can see you if it's n
c---seventeen
yeah no I mean I'm sure MPAA ratings
tend to be a little bit generous in
these situations anyway guys thanks for
telling us that this trailer was that a
lot of people were waiting for it I
thought I knew it yeah it's the first
time she's ever been like can we watch
the trailer some people are posting it
all over my Facebook page
well thank you for that and Lauren's
friends thank you if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe right here oh
right here is that where you're pointing
this is the button to subscribe to
Ryan's Channel and I have a channel and
this is the button to subscribe to my
channel
and then we'll just go like here and
that time little while e10 it's little
while well okay give me a shout-out
please
yeah a little Y little will well Wylie
happy ten you deserve a shout-out are
you ten years old is that why you're a
little widely ten amazing 19:10 the fact
that your parents let you watch YouTube
where Ted is favorite number it might be
it might be ten my sex
that's the devil's favorite number I'm
the devil no wonder you're so desirable
[Laughter]
my stare he has like this cool calm when
I go why they thanks for watching
robots you know I yeah Aaron AP
hey Ryan you're so cool and funny please
give me a shout-out it would make my day
well you're welcome for your day made
your day has been made my friend enjoy
it go out into public did you hear about
the couple that it was arrested in
Florida for having sex on a public beach
no that'd be cool though great way to
get her arrested I would love to get
arrested for something like that and
there was like a grandmother that filmed
it so she could show the police nice
what a pervert grandmother Aaron AP I
hope you're that guy that would be cool
man
that'd be so [ __ ] cool if we were
actually talking man I would want advice
on how you got a girl to agree with that
did you ever have sex on the beach in
public no no what if it was a nude beach
no it's still in public okay would you
ever go to a nude beach yeah yeah you
think you know it's pretty cool it's
pretty cool we should go sometime
I don't want to see you naked ouch
all right next Jaquan green is that how
I say that yeah Jake one can be he said
Ryan man next time Lauren comes on key
to know that she's awesome thanks JB
this is what you call a shadow you you
didn't even answer shout out yeah end it
though cuz Lauren you are awesome thank
you you really are despite the fact that
you will not see me naked even though
I've offered many it's why I'm like see
me basically naked on some of your
videos yeah I mean I've lost like two to
three pounds since then I saw someone
naked who was it oh we can't reveal no
it's a secret it would be pretty
inappropriate if I just said the trouble
with that person but it was Lauren
wasn't Lauren it's okay this other girl
has bigger boobs than me I hope you
watch this too no were you look good you
look good you know a great body Lauren
all right the first time I spent in
bikini I was like
you have a really good body like damn I
licked my lips yeah and then my my penis
just I just came right away it was weird
it wasn't it was like I have that effect
on men I can make them spontaneously
orgasm yeah I wasn't even erect it was
awesome yeah Oh your superpower to make
guys come that be so [ __ ] cool that'd
be awesome you have to focus on them
super that's your orgasm come maybe a
week really I like the whole palm idea
of like yeah exactly
now be [ __ ] awesome anyway thanks
Jared be alright Jeremy
bye bye